every week all 50 governors join in a
conference call
to discuss state responses to covet 19.
but some republican governors are
frustrated
that president biden and vice president
harris have not
joined these meetings they've not been
on these coordination calls at all
so who is leading the federal and state
coveted response of all people
new york's andrew cuomo whose mandates
last march led to over 15 000 deaths of
residents inside nursing homes
joining me now fox senior meteorologist
and author of make your own sunshine
a woman who does that a lot of us want
to help her make her sunshine as well
janisteen janice as you may know has
lost both of her in-laws to covid
obviously breaking the heart of her and
her husband and her family
and we have this this information now
this elevation
of one of their worst to guide the rest
of the governors
janice what are your thoughts on this
i'm not surprised anymore tammy i mean
from the very beginning
i've been shouting from the rooftops for
almost a year now
about the governor covering up the
numbers now we know
he did because his top aide admitted in
a
closed-door meeting with democratic
lawmakers that they were covering up the
numbers then of course his book tour
four million dollars uh for a book that
profited off the deaths of our loved
ones
uh the friends and family coveted tests
of course that he gave
to his friends and his family like chris
cuomo
and company while people were begging to
have coveted tests so that they could
see their dying loved ones in
nursing homes so i guess i'm not
surprised but i have put in a request
for peter ducey
to ask the press secretary when he sees
her this week uh
why he's still in control excellent
because you know their their argument is
their excuses well he's head of the
governor's association by the way that
should change
it's clear that should change but
there's no there's no
necessary rule that says he has to do it
but
it's fascinating in that you know people
think now this guy could get reelected
uh yeah we've got the the recall in
california it looks like it's now going
to be official of gavin newsom so we'll
have some justice there
but this is about literally life and
death the the worst of what we
see in politicians being protected
by the democratic establishment now i've
never known and people on this network
have never known
your party your politics we know you're
the best meteorologist out there saved
lives during sandy
are the you're the one who stands up and
says what is is needed to be said
beyond politics what what is what do you
make of it
with the democratic party someone like
joe biden and harris
ignoring those meetings and then putting
this kind of a man in charge what does
it say to you
it's excruciating uh it's soul-crushing
to see him on television the
first press conference he's actually had
reporters at
since december it's like seeing your
abuser on television that's a great
point
every single day still leading still
leading the state
when we've got at least four major
investigations into him
he can't lead properly he can't conduct
press conferences with reporters he has
to resign he's told us he won't resign
and of course the whole impeachment
process is just a sham
lawmakers in albany are spineless
it's different here and his one thing he
did say about the
women accusing him of of sexual
harassment and assault was that they're
looking for attention
that they're just that they're just it's
all about them that they're looking for
attention
and that in that he did nothing wrong
and that of course
means that what he think what he did he
felt was just fine
because that's part of the problem
though isn't it in each one of these
instances
the cover-up uh the getting rid of the
order from be
online blocking the ability for us to
get real the real count of people who
died because of his order
uh it's an extraordinary display of
arrogance
and and uh almost kind of a
dangerousness
of a carelessness about other human
beings that that are around him
directly and even indirectly do you
think there will be damage nationally
because of his
influence at these meetings because he
seems now to be the leader of the cove
response with governors
i think people have to grow a spine and
they have to speak out
and they have to say this isn't right
anymore and there's more marks against
this governor
than any other governor in this state
and he needs to go
well he does and uh because of your work
and your voice
people have become a bit uh braver in
this regard and it's very clear what
we've got and i really appreciate you
joining me tonight i know you're busy
and
you work uh so much so thank you so much
for being here janice appreciate it
anything for you my friend thank you
thank you dear all right